answer it how many times a year do you
go in the pool yeah I didn't go to the
beach by myself because none of my
friends wanted to question because none
of my friends do
how many times a year do you go in a
pool on average 12 months out of the
year how many times this year Joe in
general how many times would you say you
go in a pool in a calendar year I have
no idea take a step bro no it's a
podcast because you refuse to go to the
beach with me I would ask my point is
and you refuse why does that not shut
down Joe why does it not come you said
every one of my friends refused to go to
the beach and I had to stay in the pool
because none of my friends would go to
the beach the last two times we went
away yeah I said I want to go to the
beach and you refuse to go does that
happen I would have went every day if
any of my lazy
yeah and my point is you don't even go